did your parents were they encouraging
with you singing over they cuz my mom is
an educator so she was kind of slightly
like hmm I think you should maybe still
go to college like where your parents I
think I mean they were definitely
encouraging but I think my my dad
especially was a little bit more
skeptical of the you know this whole
thing as a career I think because my
whole family was like so far removed
from like anything to do with the
industry like they didn't know what it
was they didn't think it was like a real
thing that you could do with your life
and I mean realistically it doesn't
happen everyone so I did get really
lucky but yeah they were definitely you
know trying to persuade me to like go to
college and do the whole like take the
educational route but thankfully this
happened before I could do that so I
worked out that's awesome what kind of
what kind of music did your parents like
when you were young like is your sound
is really rad I was I think it's
interesting to know people I was the
youngest in my family so I had all these
different influences coming at me so
what what were your parents like what
did you what music did you grow up
around um well my mom listened to a lot
of Italian music were Italian so she you
know was born and raised there so she
played a lot of Italian music and then
my dad played a lot of like traditional
like you know Beatles and Queen and I'm
not even just saying this because it's
you right now but he loved your album
like we I grew up like my dad we went on
this road trip we were like driving to
Florida and that's the only thing he
played for the entirety of the two days
of your driving and I loved it I loved
it I mean I love your music I want to
listen to it anyways but like my dad was
obsessed with I know I swear to God like
I'm not even just saying I know your
entire first album off my heart because
of my dogs you mentioned your mother
loved Italian music that's cool that
your mom was listen to that when you had
that in your ear like growing up not
ever kid gets that subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going